italian
dear
president of italy the prime minister of
italy and mario draghi with us
today prime minister let me start by
thanking you for accepting
our invitation to address the european
parliament as part
of our this is europe debates where
together with european leaders we
discuss
our common agenda for europe's future
we know dear colleagues prime minister
draghi as a committed european
who as president of the european central
bank already steered
the eurozone out of a crisis that could
have seriously undermined our monetary
union
prime minister it is largely thanks to
your vision
your commitment and your steady hand
that we got through
you gave confidence to our people and to
our banks
and i have no doubt that we can rely on
your expertise as europe again
faces challenges of a different kind but
there are just that are just as
existential in nature
after the russian army's illegal and
unjustifiable invasion of ukraine
europe faces another
whatever it takes moment we have seen
unprecedented european coordination
solidarity and unity against this war
and this must
remain the blueprint for us
going forward be it
on further sanctions
on sending aid to ukraine on
disentangling ourselves from energy
dependence on the kremlin
helping
the millions
forced to flee or building a new
security and defense
union so prime minister you guided
your country through the worst of times
coming out
from the pandemic stronger
we know that we must take stock of
lessons learned
and ensure that we have the flexibility
that we need to care
for our populations
we must build our future in a
sustainable manner that protects the
next generation and we can do this
and i know that we will look to you for
a way
forward
prime minister let me also thank italy
and the italian people for your
leadership on migration in the
mediterranean you have borne the
responsibility thrust upon you in a
humane
and value-based approach and it is now
on us to ensure a way forward where
italy and other states do not
feel alone
next week on europe day we will receive
the conclusions from the conference on
the future of europe the onus will be on
to us
to listen and to act and in terms of
responding
to people's demands on policy changes in
health
climate security and more
no suggestion for change
should be off limits because if not now
then when
presidente alayna
members of the european parliament
citizens
i'm very pleased to be here
at the heart and in the cradle of
european democracy let me begin by
paying tribute to the memory of david
sasoli who was president of the european
parliament during difficult years
[Applause]
during the pandemic the parliament
continued to meet
take discussions take decisions
and that shows its institutional
vitality
and is a testament to mr sasoli's
leadership
he never stopped
working
towards
a new project of hope as he called it in
his last speech to the european council
he worked for a europe that innovates
protects and enlightens and this vision
of europe is today more necessary than
ever before
i'd like to thank president mitzola and
all of you
for your contribution
in moving forward this idea
every day
the war in ukraine
means that europe is facing one of the
greatest crises
in its history it's a security
humanitarian energy and economic crisis
all rolled into one
our countries
are still dealing in addition with the
consequences of the greatest health
crisis we've had in the last 100 years
the european response to the pandemic
was an effective and brave one
scientific research
enabled us
in an unprecedentedly fast manner to
develop vaccines
that prevented contagion
and reduced the severity of the disease
we organized the most impressive
vaccination campaign of recent history
which has enabled us to sell save lives
put children back into school and
relaunch our economies
we adopted next generation eu
the first major european reconstruction
project
funded
through a contribution made by everyone
to deal with the specific requirements
of every member state individually
this determination and readiness to act
this spirit of solidarity
they need to be the things that guide us
in the challenges we now face
the institutions
that our predecessors have built over
decades have served european citizens
well
but they're inadequate
for the situation that arises today
the pandemic
and the war
have meant that european institutions
have had to take on unprecedented levels
of
responsibility the
geopolitical situation is changing
rapidly and we have to move and move
fast
we need to ensure
that managing the crises that we're
living through
don't lead us back to our starting point
we need to move
to
a fairer and more sustainable economic
and social model
we need pragmatic federalism
which embraces all areas struck by the
current changes
the economy
energy policy security policy
i mentioned
pragmatic federalism but i should also
add
that
our european values of peace
solidarity
and humanity
need to be defended now more than ever
now more than ever
it is difficult for individual states to
defend these values and it will continue
to be more and more difficult
we need pragmatic federalism yes
but we also need
a perfect federalism
this
is the start of a path
that will lead to
treaty revision and if that's going to
be the case we should embrace it
[Applause]
if we manage from the tragic events of
recent years we can take
steps forward and if we can make our
institutions more effective and make
them better able to find solutions for
our citizens
well then
i think
that we will be able to build a europe
in which people feel proud
the russian attack on ukraine
has called into question the european
union's greatest achievement piece on
our continent
this piece was based
on respect for territorial borders the
rule of law
democratic sovereignty
it was based on the use of diplomacy
as the means to resolve crises between
states
this pace was based on respect for human
rights
which have been violated in butcher
mario paul and everywhere else
that the russian army has used violence
against innocent citizens
[Applause]
we need to support ukraine
its government and its people
as president zielenski has
and continues to request
[Applause]
this is a war of aggression
and
it's clear
who's invading and who's resisting
we want ukraine to remain a free
democratic and sovereign country
protecting ukraine means protecting
ourselves
it means
protecting
our
security
and our project of security and
democracy that we've built over 70 years
helping ukraine means first and foremost
working in favor of peace
our priority is to achieve a ceasefire
as soon as possible so that we can save
lives and enable
interventions
in favor of civilians which are
currently very difficult
a ceasefire would also further boost or
would foster negotiations which haven't
yet achieved the desired results
europe can and should have a central
role in fostering dialogue
and we need to do that because of our
geography
which
means that we're close to this war
it puts us in the front line when it
comes to dealing with all the possible
consequences of the war we also have a
duty as a result of our history
which has shown that we're able to build
stable and lasting peace
even in the wake of bloody conflicts
italy is a founding member state of the
european union we're a country that
believes deeply in peace and we're
therefore committed to being in the
front line when it comes to achieving a
diplomatic solution
the war is already having a deep impact
on our countries
since the start of the conflict around
5.3
million people have left ukraine and
come to the european union
and mainly these are women and children
that's
more than
double the numbers of refugees that were
present in the european union at the end
of 2020 the number then stood at around
2.5 million
italy believes in the european values
of welcoming
and solidarity we
have
welcomed
thanks to the generosity of families
volunteers and ngos
over 150 000 ukrainian refugees and i'd
like to thank all those who have
welcomed them
other countries poland romania germany
slovakia have made even greater efforts
many refugees want to go home as soon as
possible and some of them already
started doing that
nevertheless
we don't know how the conflict is going
to develop and we don't know how long
it's going to last
we need to be ready
to continue along the path we've taken
to ensure that ukrainian refugees
are integrated into our societies as
well as possible
in economic terms
the crisis has
disturbed international supply chains
and has caused volatility in the prices
of raw materials and energy
ukrainian food supplies
have crumbled as a result of the
devastation of war and the input the
export blocks that have been put
by the russians on the ports in the
black sea and the azov sea
the ukraine is the fourth largest
supplier of food to the european union
it produces around half
of our wheat supplies and a quarter of
our vegetable oils
russia and ukraine also make up around a
quarter of global grain exports
almost 50 countries in the world depend
on them for over 30 percent of their
imports
in march
the prices of cereals and the main
food supplies reached historic highs and
there's a major risk that the increase
in prices as well as a lack of
availability in fertilizers will produce
food crises
according to the fao
13 million more people
could suffer hunger between 2023 and
2026 as a result of the war in ukraine
many countries
particularly in africa and the middle
east are more vulnerable to these risks
and could
go through periods of social and
political instability
we can't allow that to happen
our commitment
via development banks multilateral
financial institutions and our bilateral
commitments
need to be ramped up
when it comes to energy
the price of oil which
in december and january was between 70
and 90 dollars a barrel
is now around 105 a barrel it was it
peaked at 130 in march
the price
of gas
has also gone up massively around it's
around five times higher than it was a
year ago
these
increases were already being observed
prior to the crisis
but they have pushed inflation to levels
that hasn't been seen for decades
in the euro zone
inflation is at 7.5 percent
in april
compared to a year ago and it is having
a major
impact on families purchasing powers
and
businesses levels of production
the european economy is slowing down in
the first three months of 2022
the eurozone's gdp increased by 0.2
percent
when compared to the last three months
of 2021
the imf
predicts that the european union will
grow by 2.9 percent this year
compared to the four percent forecasts
that were in place just a little while
ago
each of these crises would require a
strong reaction from the european union
but
given that they're all coming together
means that we decisively need to
accelerate the decision making and
integration process
during the coming months we need to show
european citizens that we're
up to the task of ensuring that europe
can be up to its history its values and
its role in the world europe needs to be
stronger more cohesive and more
sovereign europe needs to be able to
take the future into its own hands
as chancellor merkel said
during the last 75 years european
integration
has often been the best
response to common challenges
the founding fathers of the european
union were aware that economic
development and social progress
were difficult to achieve
using the resources of individual member
states
they
saw the supranational model as the only
one that could unite the interests of
european peoples and would enable
the european union to influence events
that they otherwise wouldn't have been
able to have an influence on
integration has been a gradual process
there have been crises and
resets there have been internal disputes
and there has sometimes been extreme
resistance
the result
has been built bit by bit and sector by
sector
the
european union couldn't be built as an
ideal city as robert schuman said
after the second world war
europe responded with the first
institution
for
economic cooperation
they
restored trade
you in these institutions and then you
had the european coal and steel
community
which did away with
customs duties
and other barriers which stopped these
goods
flowing freely then in 1956 we had the
suez crisis and this further sped up the
process towards the treaty of rome
the bretton woods system collapsed in
1971 and when that happened european
countries reacted
by creating
the
european
snake and then the european monetary
system then there was growing skepticism
in the 1980s and the response was a
series of targeted interventions
proposed by the delaware commission and
then there was the single european act
in 1986
at the end of the soviet union
and the reunification of germany
europe
followed up
with the signing of the maastricht
treaty and the creation of monetary
union and then enlarged eastwards
the eurozone
crisis
around a decade ago led to a boosting
and a modernization of our economic
institutions first and foremost among
them the european central bank
the pandemic as i mentioned earlier
brought us together again
and led to the creation of next
generation eu
as you can see this has been a long path
of integration and has changed our lives
for the better
because it's given us peace
prosperity
and a social model which we can be proud
of
the single market
hasn't only
led to the re-launching of the european
economy in a at a difficult time but has
led to protection for consumers and
workers
and forms of social welfare that are
unique in the world
we've built democratic institutions that
are common to all of us such as this
parliament
and here we can achieve shared decisions
and ensure that fundamental rights are
respected
we have made the european union
an area that is not only economic
but an area that defends rights and
human dignity
and this is a heritage
that we cannot throw away
now
it is time to move forward further on
this path
on the 9th of par of march
on the 9th of may excuse me the
conference on the future of europe will
conclude
and the final results suggest that we
need to be ambitious
we want to be in the front line of
designing this new europe
the geopolitical situation has suddenly
become much more uncertain and more
dangerous
and we need to deal with economic and
social emergencies and guarantee
the safety of our citizens
investments in defense
need to be carried out with a view to
improving our collective capacities as
the a european union and nato
the last european council took an
important decision when it adopted the
strategic compass that needs to be
rapidly implemented
we need to go further than these initial
steps however and build
effective coordination between defense
systems
our
expenditure on
security is around three times russian
expenditure
but uh there are many many different
systems
which this expenditure is spread across
this is inefficient and
is an obstacle to the construction of
genuine european defense
strategic autonomy in defense
requires first and foremost greater
efficiency when it comes to defense
spending in europe
we need
to
hold a conference to rationalize and
optimize
our
defense spending and investment
in addition
the construction
of a common defense
system needs to be accompanied by a
single foreign policy and effective
decision-making mechanisms
we need to get over
the principle of unanimity
[Applause]
we need to move forward
from the principle of unanimity
which leads to a logic of
intra-governmental decisions we need to
move towards decisions taken on the
basis of a qualified majority
[Applause]
a europe which is capable of taking
rapid decisions is a europe that is more
critical uh credible excuse me vis-a-vis
citizens and the rest of the world
the first move needs to relate to the
enlargement process
we need to fully integrate countries
that have european
aspirations this is not a threat to the
european project
this is part of its implementation
italy supports the immediate opening up
of accession negotiations with
albania and the republic of north
macedonia in line with the council
conclusions of march 2020 we want to
boost negotiations with serbia and
montenegro and we want to support the
expectations of cosagobo and bosnia and
herzegovina we're in favour of all of
these countries joining the european
union and we also want ukraine as a
member of the european union
we need
to
follow
the path that we've designed
but we need also to move along it as
rapidly as possible
solidarity shown vis-a-vis ukrainian
refugees
needs to push us to european level of
management of migrants who come from
other theatres of war
in general we need to establish an
effective european mechanism to manage
migration flows which
goes further than the treaty of dublin
[Applause]
we need to
boost repatriation agreements and ensure
that they're effective but we also need
to boost legal channels for migration to
the european
union particular we need to pay more
attention to the mediterranean
given its strategic location
as a bridge towards africa and the
middle east
we can't see the mediterranean
simply as a border area where we need to
put up barriers
many
young
countries border the mediterranean and
they are ready to put their enthusiasm
into relations with the european union
we need to build genuine partnerships
with these countries not only economic
but also political and social in nature
the mediterranean needs to be an area of
peace prosperity and progress
energy policy is an area in which
mediterranean countries
can and should
play a key role for the future of europe
europe faces
a profound
geopolitical reorientation
which will shift our strategic axis
towards the south
war
in ukraine has shown how vulnerable many
are con of our countries are
and how dependent on moscow
italy is one of the most exposed member
states around 40 percent of the natural
gas that we import comes from russia
we don't have coal we don't have nuclear
power
we barely have any oil either
given
this
dependency
we find ourselves vulnerable and this is
dangerous in geopolitical terms
italy intends to take every measure
necessary to defend our security and
european security
we've supported the sanctions
that the european union has levied on
russia including those on the energy
sector and we will continue to do that
with the same determination in the
future
recent weeks
we
have
moved in a rapid and determined master
to diversify our gas supplies
and we've taken important measures
to speed up the production of renewable
energy which is crucial to make our
economic growth more sustainable
reducing our
russian imports of fossil fuels
mean that it's inevitable for europe to
look to the mediterranean to satisfy its
energy requirements
i'm referring
to
gas fields
because gas can be a transition fuel but
i'm also referring to the massive
opportunities offered by renewables in
africa and the middle east
the countries of southern europe and
italy in particular have a strategic
location when it comes to this energy
we can act as a bridge towards northern
european countries
this central position will depend on the
investments that we can make
at the same time
we need to find solutions to protect
families and businesses from increased
energy costs
we need to moderate people's bills
and fuel prices and this will ensure
that sanctions are more sustainable
since the start of the crisis
italy has asked for europe to put a
ceiling on gas prices imported from
russia
russia
sells
almost two-thirds of its natural gas
exports to europe
many of those go through
gas pipelines that can't be reorientated
to
other buyers
our proposal would entail using our
bargaining power to reduce these massive
costs that are weighing down our
economies
as well as that this measure would
enable us to reduce the amounts that we
send to president putin on a daily basis
which inevitably end up funding his
military campaign
we also
want to
review
the mechanism that sets electricity
prices which is based on the most
expensive form of energy which is
usually gas
even in normal small times
the generation of energy from
fossil fuels is more expensive
than generating energy from renewables
and this is a problem that's going to
get worse over time
if we increase
the quota of renewable energy into our
energy mix we'll have prices that are
even more
non-representative of the cost of
generating energy if we stick to the
current system
there's currently massive volatility on
the gas market and the way that prices
are calculated is
inappropriate
gas prices then
end up being reflected in the price of
electricity we now get a lot of energy
from our renewables but uh the cost of
that
it being is low but is not reflected in
bills
in italy the price of electricity has
gone up
four times from what it was last year
and this is having a major impact on our
economy
the italian government and other
governments have reacted to protect
businesses and families particularly
those that are the most vulnerable
italy alone has spent
around 30 billion euros on that just
this year
managing
this
has many
limits however sustainability for public
finances for example
the problem is a systemic one and needs
to be resolved using structural
solutions that break the link between
the price of gas and that of electricity
the problem of energy costs will be one
that we look at during the next european
council and we need strong and immediate
decisions that will benefit all european
citizens
the various crises
that derive from the conflict in ukraine
are taking place at a time
when
europe already
faced massive requirements in terms of
expenditure the digital and
environmental transitions require
investments which cannot be put off
to these need to be added the costs of
the war that we need to deal with
immediately to prevent our continent
falling into recession
in both cases
these are asymmetric costs
that strike
different parts of the population and
protect productive sectors in different
ways and need to be compensated for in
different manners
there's no rational and reasonable
budget that can deal with these problems
on its own
no country can be left behind
this
on this depends on social peace in our
continent and our ability to
sustain sanctions particularly in those
countries that because of their history
are more dependent on russia the
european union has already come up with
certain tools that are useful to deal
with these challenges
and these are responses that we
established during the pandemic which
ensured that the european union had a
widespread and rapid economic recovery
we need to base ourselves on that
success
and adapt these tools to the
circumstances we now face
sure
the european
instrument
which provides temporary support
for
and for employment in an emergency
supported the labor market
the european union needs to extend the
scope of that to help
countries that request funding they need
to be provided with new funding
to
deal with the burden of energy costs
here i'm talking about reducing bills
but also providing temporary support to
the lowest paid
for example as we did yesterday to
reduce contributions for the lowest
salaries
the advantage there is that we defend
the purchasing power of families
particularly those that are the most
vulnerable
using a
loan mechanism such as shaw means that
we avoid using
subsidies
to pay for
national measures that come under
current spending in addition we're
seeing interest rates going up and
we don't want to see member states
finances getting more precarious
and
these kinds of ways of acting avoid
member states taking out debt on the
markets this helps to prevent financial
instability and this is a measure that
needs to be implemented very quickly now
because we've been in this situation for
eight nine or ten months now
this would enable
governments to intervene immediately to
support their economies now looking at
more long-term investments in areas such
as defense
energy food security and industrial
security
the model needs to be that of next
generation eu
this
idea
of
payments by installments that are made
when
objectives are achieved
provides a virtuous mechanism that
checks the quality of expenditure this
means that we're spending the resources
we're given appropriately and that's
crucial for our credibility these are
these citizens and other european
partners
as i've said
so often our partners have agreed to tax
their citizens to help italy and other
countries who have used these grants
[Applause]
good
governance doesn't
mean just responding
to current crises
we also need to move fast to anticipate
those in the future
the founding fathers showed us how to
make democracy in our continent
effective
in its transformations
european integration
is the best tool we have to deal with
these challenges
with which we're faced
today
like
at every decisive point during the
post-war period we need determination
vision but above all unity
i'm sure that we will find these
qualities again
together thank you
to the speakers on behalf of the
political groups starting with mumford
weber on behalf of the epp group you
have the floor
madam president your commissioners
to mr prime minister
welcome and first of all congratulations
to roberta who else then
the italian prime minister should start
the new dialogue between the european
parliament and the member states with
this new framing of this is europe
italy was always
a driving a driver for the european
integration
i want to mention i'll see the gasbury
and also want to mention david zazoli
a lot of european leaders came from
italy
and italy needs a strong europe but also
europe needs a strong italy thank you
dear prime minister draghi
not only for being here today but also
for your brilliant work as an ecb
president in the last decade
i want to
i want to thank you first of all for
your leadership in the last
period of time as prime minister of
italy the pandemic italy was the first
target
and
finally italy reacted in a very well
organized way
it became a kind of a role model in
managing the pandemic on the european
level it was the rrf you mentioned it my
party the european people's party with
angela merkel whistles on the line also
i want to mention that tonight other
friends
we showed that we are ready to invest in
solidarity on european union level after
the pandemic to restart our economy to
give a good idea about the future of our
economy and our european solidarity
approach
italy is
the country who get this biggest share
of this rrf
and you are showing that this money is
well spent you combine this with a
reform agenda in italy
and that is
great because for the long run a good
implementation of the recovery and
resilience fund gives us on european
level arguments for continuing
for continuation of the european
solidarity approach and also for ukraine
italy had a clear position in this
in this conflict so your clear
leadership is good for italy but also
good for europe in crisis we need more
than ever before this kind of leadership
and to also quote i'll see the the
gaspari he said once a
politician looks to the next election a
statement looks to the next generation
and europe needs more statesmen and less
tactics in europe
when we describe now the challenges of
today
you mentioned a few of them i could i
could sum up my contribution today and
say
well great let's do it now because we
have a lot of sea speeches when we see
ambitious approaches from our leaders on
the council side when i would frame let
me say the general consideration from my
party's point of view then i want to
underline that europe must avoid another
lost generation we need a europe for the
youth we have to shape a europe of hope
and a lot of fears and we have to shape
a europe of opportunities in a lot of
limitations and that's why you mentioned
it the outcome of the
conference for the future of europe is
for us a motivating starting signal to
now go further and that's why let me
really underline let me
be clear that i'm really happy that you
today is one of the first leaders on the
council side were outspoken were clear
that after this conference you are ready
for a convention we need a new power
architecture for the european union
thank you so much for this leadership
when we
speak about the concrete points
then for sure
foreign affairs and defense is a main
pillar
we experience a key of momentum in the
european union
citizens are together showing solidarity
with ukraine france and we have to step
speed up now our efforts to build up a
european defense unit integrate it for
sure into the nato
you spoke about the pragmatic
federalization of the european union
federal system of europe i want to give
you an example on this defense the
long-term idea is a european army no
doubt about this but on short term we
should focus on the european added value
for example on cyber defense it's
obvious that we are much stronger if we
do it together or on a missile defense
system it's obvious that we can protect
our airspace together much more
effective than if we do it on national
level so let's focus on the concrete
things we need these kind of flagship
projects now to make things possible
the investments would be much more
easier much more cheaper in the future
you mentioned this and also for our
military it would be much more effective
i want to underline a second point which
is uh interest important for us and that
is he only can have a good future for
our european union if we create growth
again the economic strength is the real
power base for today's european
strengthen european union and as a
central banker you know a good future
needs a union of growth but not a
union of further depths and as a family
father you also know that the most
important thing for the future of the
next generation are opportunities and
not additional burden for the next
generation so that's why when we speak
about the economic model for the future
we face
fundamental changes we didn't spoke so
much in the last weeks about china about
what is happening on the global market
but we know things are fundamentally
changing
we speak about independence in today's
european union
but this means also to have a little bit
less of globalization which was the
foundation for our economic success in
the last decades so that's why we have
to re-change and reorganize the economic
metal model also on global level and
that's why we are strongly fighting for
a single market for the free world on
the global stage we have to bring
together australia india japan all those
who are believing our values on the
economic base that can create the
precondition for the growth for tomorrow
and finally on migration
let me underline that there are no
italian greek or spanish
migrants there are only european
migrants it's a common european
challenge and that's why the european
parliament is ready for a solution you
know that we are waiting for the council
to solve the legislative
blockade on the council side let's go
now after the ukraine experience for
solving this problem
ladies and gentlemen we here today a
leader who was
ambitious for the future of europe
now it's a moment to implement things
now it's a moment to do it to make it
real that is what brings us the trust
and the support from our citizens let's
use this debate thanks to roberta met
solas initiative for creating exactly
the precondition for the delivery
process thank you so much
thank you very much mr webber
i now invite iracia garcia perez on
behalf of the s d group to take the
floor
yes thank you very much president
dear prime minister welcome to this
house which is the home of european
democracy and thank you very much for
the words that you addressed to
president sasoli because as you said
quite rightly
he very well represented the spirit of
the european project and we're going to
continue to work
to continue his work
and
bearing that spirit in mind as you've so
quite rightly said during your
presentation we're facing a whole series
of crisis which have been following on
one from the other over the past few
years and have been exacerbated now by
the war in ukraine these are not easy
challenges but the best weapon we have
is unity and determination in order to
tackle these challenges we saw this
already during
the pandemic both in from its uh
health aspect and also to taking a look
at the economic and social impact so
it's with unity and solidarity that
we're able to
move forward with next generation eu and
the key to fire facing up to the
consequences of the war russia's war in
ukraine is unity and determination
about 10 years ago when you were
president of the european central bank
and in
right in the middle of the sovereign
debt crisis and the dew mongers were
predicting the collapse of the euro you
said three famous words whatever it
takes whatever it takes
and i think this is the same spirit that
we have to show now in the face of
the challenge faced by putin to our
values and just as was the case 10 years
ago the response to this crisis has to
be
more integration because by sharing
sovereignty that's how we are stronger
and how we are better masters of our own
future but in order to continue building
up our home our house we need to lay
more bricks and we urgently need an
energy union a fiscal union a health
union and a defense union and i think we
really have to make progress in this
work because if we take a look at our
project of peace and liberty which has
been
developed and growing over the past ten
day decades and has
established peace and solidarity between
our member states and citizens it's
still not enough
and since the
schumann declaration then obviously what
our union has aimed to do is contribute
to peace and freedom based on our values
and based on
um dignity a multilateralism
unfortunately the desires of the
ukrainian citizens to become part of
this project has cost them dearly and
unlike the soviet union the european
union does not impose anything doesn't
force anybody to do anything nor does it
dominate what it does it attracts others
uh through its promises uh for the
future its values of freedom and human
dignity the kind of things that were you
know demanded by the demonstrators in
maidan in 2013 and we can't close the
doors on the ukrainian citizens by
supporting the legitimate aspirations of
ukraine it means that we have to we're
going to have to rethink our internal
policies in the union and we need a more
sustainable transitional obviously
economic
development and also from the
environmental and human viewpoint
and we have to try and move away from
imports of fossil fuels which means that
we have to diversify renewable energy
sources and make sure that any measures
we take are also affordable for
companies and families and we should not
forget our young people because they
need stable work
accessibility to
homes as well
and we really need to send out an
optimistic mess optimistic message to
these generations of young people who
demand who are demanding more and better
from the european union and they've said
as much loudly and clearly during the
conference on the future of europe they
want more social policies they want to
reduce poverty and for them it is
absolutely essential that
we broaden suspension of certain tax
measures because unless there is public
investment it's going to be impossible
for us to achieve our objectives whether
it's support to ukraine help to refugees
or any other of the
policies that we have set out and we're
not going to be able to comply with our
road map i.e a fair transition moving
away from energy fossil fuels
obviously we have we need
realistic fiscal policies at mr draghi
especially in the times that we're
living through now
and what we need to do is make sure that
we do something about those who are
making enormous profits uh
at the cost of other people because
we've seen that there are certain
companies that are making enormous
profits and there are very many families
who are falling into poverty and they
can't even pay their electricity bill so
we have to do something about these
windfall profits
of these companies in order to put right
this injustice so we have to continue to
move forward with our project but always
focusing having the well-being and
dignity of our citizens at the center of
all policies and i think we have to say
this loud and clear and repeat it so
that putin can hear this but russian the
russian people as well we're going to do
whatever it takes to guarantee the
future of our eu european union thank
you thank you very much
ms garcia perez
now on behalf of the renew group stefan
sajuna
first and foremost i would like to thank
you for your speech about the european
commitment of your government and your
contribution to the european debate
you've
finished a period that's been too long
where some european political players
have wrongly looked upon italy
with condescension and
indifference at times
which was one of the reasons perhaps for
the delay for the european reaction to
uh
giving italy aid during the pandemic
thankfully this assembly
has
reacted in a timely manner showing that
europe is
helping
italy as much as anywhere else
the recovery plan the vaccine plan have
come about partly because of
that i was recently in in romans said
that italy still needs europe and europe
still needs italy
italy's ideas and talent
italy
is no stranger to the new european
consensus which has been constructive
constructed and
heads of state and government in our
eu and the european parliament are part
of all that obviously we don't agree on
any everything particularly regarding
the tools but
objectives as well
carbon neutrality
fighting inequalities
in the new consensus our group
wants to know what you think
everyone agrees on the need to
renew our budgetary framework and to
move together on economic terms we need
to invest more
to
for green planning and innovation
and also
for our continent to come together on
strategic
terms
what do you think is the best way to
to move towards that with the reform of
the stability pact you set out a few
things but but the how is essential in
the weeks and months to come
a new consensus
has come about regarding european
solidarity since the ukraine conflict
the war
the peace and the sovereignty of europe
have been at the heart
of deliberations in all governments
we thank you for the political courage
needed for your government
to look at national
positions over the last few decades on
that school you've made declarations
but you've also
put them into actions
and
you've
earned
you've stood firm against medium
manipulation
russian media manipulation we'd like to
congratulate you for your efforts there
finally
we'd like to know
whether in the six
uh sanctioned package you support
the embargo
for all
fossil fuels from russia and whether you
think an agreement is possible over the
next few days and weeks in the council
finally regarding the conference on the
future of union uh europe
uh mr draghi which is particularly
important here in this plenary where we
talk about in inter-institutional issues
which are very important and that are
important for
the building of europe in the years to
come
in your speech i heard you say
that we can count upon italy to defend
the reforms that citizens want in europe
i'm thinking about the end of unanimity
in foreign policy you are very clear
about that
some
of your colleagues need to come in line
with that
but to take some of these proposals
further the right of initiative of the
parliament on
transnational lists
there are important things for our
institution to do there too
finally mr draghi the french and
slovenian elections over the last couple
of weeks have shown us
that
europe
is at an important juncture
it's good that populists don't even say
any more that they want to leave the eu
urophobes haven't come up with solutions
at the moment but their simplistic ideas
are still out there and will
perhaps carry on prospering
because of the lack of hope socially and
and
economically we need to move towards a
social democratic green europe and we
hope that we can count on you for that
and on italy
the renew group stands alongside you in
meeting those objectives thank you
i give the floor now on behalf of the
green group to phillip lambert
president draghi welcome
welcome to the european parliament with
you at the head of the government in
paulde gentiloni
in the european commission i think we
can say that italy has renewed its firm
european commitment
uh equal to the responsibilities of a
founding member of the european union
and the third economic power of the
union
and it's uh
obviously you have assumed your own
share of responsibility a bit more than
that in
europe and that's when it comes to
welcoming
immigrants
because for many years italy has been in
the front line in the mediterranean and
they've taken in more than its fair
moral share of immigrants without
getting the necessary solidarity from
its european allies
and i would like to say that during
under the previous parliament the
european parliament had been willing on
the basis of a broader majority to
review the dublin rules and i think we
are going to have to get past this
doctrine of unanimity in the council so
that we can move towards qualified
majority especially when it comes to uh
immigration which i mean it's the case
anyway
whatever it takes with these three words
when you were president of the european
central bank you had taken the measure
of the challenge we were facing
in the face of attacks on the financial
markets one had to salvage the euro
whatever it takes and whatever it takes
has now become the alpha an omega of
economic policy within the european
union we have to
save lives but also support workers and
businesses whatever it takes to overcome
the impact of the crisis
and today with the invasion putin's
invasion in ukraine something that's
attest to our determination and once
again the european union is going to
have to do whatever it takes to help
ukrainians and guarantee our
energy autonomy which is absolutely
essential
italy is exemplary because they have
acted in a spirit of unity at the side
of their european allies and this
in spite of their huge dependency on
russia
and contrary to others they have very
well understood that this war is a
moment where the european union can
prove that it is able to be a geologic
geopolitical power
in the immediate future the efforts
being made by italy to diversify its um
sources of energy
uh fuel uh fossil energy uh
understandable but obviously this is not
a long-term solution and it's only a
transition towards renewable energies
and energy sobriety together with a
guaranteeing assist
sustainable security of supply that we
can have energy independence and also
face up to our climate uh challenges
so i hear the voice of your government
well on the country your environment
minister
uh who keeps going on about uh nuclear
return to nuclear power in
italy which was rejected uh massively by
the italian people only a ten about ten
years ago
then obviously
we have
and then at the same time your
government seems to be questioning a
renewal of your main
building renovation program the super
eco bonus 110
which is an
example of good practices by the
european commission
so mario draghi the central banker
refused to integrate these climate
constraints into monetary policies
saying that this was up to the political
decision makers
so i've heard that and
i'm hoping that that mario draghi head
of the italian government has heard the
message because obviously
those invalid politicians have to
uh demonstrate their leadership and
energy transition is absolutely
essential not only climate terms but
also geopolitical terms
obviously you have spoken in favor of a
reform of budgetary rules and i think we
have to try and move even more swiftly
to do this and move towards a true
budget union
because it's only all member states
together that are going to
turn the european union into a world
leader of
ecological transition and solidarity and
a respected geopolitic geopolitical
power
so we need um
joint loans to finance by
a shared common taxes to finance that
common project sir
and
your country which is one of the main
beneficiaries of next-gen eu is a
prototype of a budget union of this kind
and i think the
best service that it can do today is to
ensure that this become a european
project and prove its success so it can
last in the future
obviously we've heard about the
conference on the future of europe and
those who speak in favor of a reformed
european treaties and this is what it
takes this is what is absolutely
essential for this pragmatic
um federalism this idealist is
idealistic as well this is something
that you're speaking in favor of that
president draghi your own political
capital in your own country and within
the european union is
undoubtedly
huge and i urge you very much to
mobilize this political capital so the
european union can become a key actor in
this
century and i'd just like to say avanti
i give the floor now on behalf of the
ideal group to marco zandi
grazie
thank you president mitsula
commissioner gentilloni
mr draghi welcome back to the european
parliament
as you've reminded us we're up against
a critical moment in european history
with a wall a few kilometers from us
which
requires
a strong
but credible
response in this dark period we're up
against
unfortunately over the last few weeks
we've seen the the initial conviction to
be strong and stand together member
states european leaders and institutions
has
collapsed
looking at
the
strategy
in terms of how europe is which means
that we're weak and in
ineffective and we can be blackmailed we
need to solve these problems before we
look to the future
we need to think about the choices we
made in the past
we need to find new solutions
to problems and we need to do that
quickly
the dependence on countries like russia
has been because of political decisions
and it's mean that our prosper
prosperity depends on low-cost energy
imports
and this is this is linked to our
production levels and it's mean that
entire economic sectors have been
paralyzed
but the the strategy that we need
requires deep change to our
industrial and socio-economic
models a few days
after the 1st of may i'd like to to
raise the issue of work
purchasing power strategic
security of the eu
means that we can't just
have
products made in just one country
outside the uber that need to be made in
eu but for that to happen
costs will go up and you're very much
aware of this you're in econo economist
economic freedom
means paying more
and
those products need to be accessible to
workers who need to be better paid
looking at a race to the bottom which is
what we saw in unfettered globalization
we need to reverse that trend
trend
for security because of security risks
apart from other issues but i'd like to
stress one point here
we need sustainable investment and for
that we need to stand together
and have a race at the top
call for
quality sustain costs but we need to
have the right wages
we need to be
more independent in terms of uh supply
but we need to not
make the same mistakes
we made in the past going from russia's
embrace to china's embrace is not a
solution
the highest office in the union need to
learn from the past think about
the responses
to the dramatic conflict in ukraine
and
we need to think about the right path to
take
we need to trust
in terms of trusting on one
country to set the strategy for an
entire continent
that's not something we can carry on in
terms of ideology that's more
ideological than pragmatic pragmatic we
need to be more chromatic less
ideologically
more concrete steps less
torque
we need to take action on the
environment defense and so on
we need a true eu response to the energy
crisis looking at the energy mix that
varies from country to country
lifestyles are different i go from
country to country so i hope that
the way things are
is that
in terms of reality and metaphor we can
move on from the one-size-fits-all
rhetoric
which
means that uh
in some areas
europe is an obstacle not
a solution we need to change course
we and we need to do that
within time
this is an opportunity
mr drag drag
we have the opportunity to change you've
talked about changing the european
treaties that is
the biggest thing but there are smaller
things we can do together before that
i hope that the union in our country
takes the right track in terms of
looking at management of the problems
that we have in our country and in
europe
and we stand we'll always stand together
with you on that thank you
now on behalf of the eci group rafaela
thank you
president uh commissioner gentilani
prime minister dragul i'd also like to
welcome you to the parliament on behalf
of my political group this is a
difficult and complex time
we certainly need the call for unity
which everyone has made and i think
that
is
a
clear
condemnation of currently what of what's
currently going on i mean we have
an attack
on the values of freedom democracy and
peace and also humanitarian disaster and
we have to be clear
on all of this and as a political group
as the conservative group we've always
been clear on our position and we've
strongly supported the line that has
been generally taken and i want to say
that
because
that leads to
a reflection also at the national level
i mean i think there has been hesitation
in the past
but uh i think we have been supportive
in our attitude
to actions and i think also it's
important to be critical now i mean the
idea of standing together and moving
towards the future without thinking
about what's happened in the past and
thinking about the mistakes that we've
made in the past is wrong because we
risk making the same mistakes
so i think it's important to think about
certain elements
i mean we're certainly not particularly
enthusiastic let's say about the work of
the conference on the future of europe
which risks ending up as basically a
back slapping exercise and also
the
calls for
the need to put the mediterranean
at the heart of what we do
and working with africa i mean i think
that
really goes
against what we've seen during recent
months and years we've seen turkey and
russia and also china more present there
thanks to the errors that we've made so
i think it's important to reflect on our
errors i mean also those that have led
to a lack of independence in terms of
strategic autonomy i mean we've had
an industrial policy that hasn't led to
agriculture real food and energy
independence and we need that if we're
going to look to the future in a
credible and serious manner
we also believe that it's crucial to
establish
clear
strategies and this also on migration
where there are lots of other errors i
mean what's happened over previous years
has happened and we've seen that the
reason
was
that there was a lack of agreement
because
we have seen certain countries open up
to genuine war refugees
and they need to be genuine war refugees
and we need to analyze what's happened
in the past in a critical manner we need
self-criticism here we're able to make
proposals
and your very authoritative and credible
in doing that
but as a member of the european
parliament as a political group leader
but also as an italian we would ask for
two clear proposals to be made firstly
strong
clear
action as you said to deal with the
issue of sanctions and to support that
with a compensation
fund which links the needs and
requirements of individual member states
in terms of energy but also in terms of
exports which is another key factor that
may well bring a country such as ours to
its knees and then the second
request relates to our national
political debate georgia milani has
asked for a modification of our national
plan on recovery and resilience this is
something that has just been launched
but it's already outdated
article 21 of the rrf envisages that in
extraordinary cases you can intervene to
change the
choices that have been made
and let's face it that this is a tool
that was envisaged for the pandemic
and
to produce economic growth but now we've
got war i mean that's certainly an
extraordinary circumstance so we need to
adapt the tool
now this isn't a national issue alone as
well i mean you like many others have
said that italy is the number one
beneficiary of all these resources
and it's there that we need a strong
response because the success or failure
of the italian plan will be the success
or failure of the whole strategy
we're not
used to simply waiting to see what
happens so we would ask you to assess
this proposal in the interest of italy
but also with a view to
young people and european businesses in
the future thank you very much the left
group to martin shared the one
thank you president
prime minister draghi the italian
government
is very firmly proceeding against the
russian oligarchs seizing some of their
assets
and then of course
in order to
pay for the costs of maintenance then of
course there are seized goods as well
and i would like that
the assets that you've seized from the
russian oligarchs be made available in
some way to the ukraine children to help
them feed and then all these enormous
cars as well
you've got a crisis windfall tax for
energy companies they really have to
be brought to task to pay
what their money what they owe and
when it comes to big attack tech and
pharmaceutical companies
uh what about their profits as well
because there are those who are making a
benefit obviously in profit from the
crisis uh the war what about the defense
uh industry
and you're asking for various kinds of
taxes uh bravo uh to put a break on
certain things the german government is
actually acting rather hesitantly when
it comes to russian oligarchs
and uh is um being a little hesitant in
some other measures
this is europe this is the title of the
debate uh prime minister draghi so
obviously we have to think in terms of
the recent past the financial economic
crises where you played
an absolutely
marvelous leading role there are those
who've called you super mario in fact
and as president of ecb
then in greece uh
you turn the uh
money
the tap off for money to um the then
government because of course uh they
weren't taking the right kind of
measures but then of course the
pensioners uh
those uh receiving
um
benefits that all the money
in these uh
sectors and also in the health sector
well the funds just dropped and the
troika of course
uh we saw
that um when they intervened the debt
was 150 percent of national debt it's
about 160 now and all of a sudden
we let's just consider if somebody came
up with the idea um that
we had to have the same kind of um
austerity measures
in italy as in greece
for example what if
[Music]
the money was
stopped the money that was turned off
from you as well in italy
because of course this would uh
cause and damage at the time whatever it
takes in the eyes of the public or the
big investors and the banks
meant that people thought that europe
would have a good future
but of course now we have exploding
energy prices food prices if we had
whatever it takes moment to spare people
from that
so that wages wouldn't be gobbled up
whatever it takes
if we could
protect the climate that's what we need
and also in the face of dictators so we
need a whatever it takes moment as well
for the planet thank you
thank you uh mr sudawan next on behalf
of the non-attached members titiana
begin
thank you very much president metzeler
mr draghi welcome back to the european
parliament
during the pandemic we saw how many
positive things europe can do for
citizens as you've said
with next generation eu
we saved our economy
and created the right conditions for the
recovery with sure we set aside billions
to help the unemployed
and vulnerable people it hasn't been
easy many european leaders are skeptical
about what we need to do
but uh solidarity and unity prevailed
thanks to the eu putin didn't get his
way in ukraine which is good but
not even we have been able to get what
we want namely peace
colleagues
after
more than two months of conflict it's
the time to use diplomacy to save the
ukrainian people from further death and
suffering
ukraine's right to do to defend itself
is sacrosanct but let's not forget that
our final objective needs to be peace
but let's learn from these difficult
months and starts to work towards energy
independence for gas from russian gas
and oil
let's fight the energy pandemic
with the same instruments that we use
during the health pandemic let's
replicate the success of the recovery
fund and approve an energy recovery fund
and that's what the five star movement
wants to do to speed up
renewables
not all member states have been able to
or use
the financial mean how have the
financial means to get the right
investments in renewables we need
europe's firepower for this and
we need to make sure that europe is
successful once it and once again
and
it's shameful
the the big oil players make billions of
from oil but one in seven italians can't
pay their
energy bills because they're too
expensive
galloping inflation
is taking away purchasing power from
families and and then people wonder why
we
why europeans aren't having children
anymore we need a european minimum
salary i agree mr draghi when you say we
need to reform dublin we need solidarity
we need responsibility responsibility as
we've seen
with
ukrainian refugees
i'd like to remind you that thanks to
the contribution of the five star
movement
the this plenary voted in the four laws
of the waste package
you can't use incinerators across all
countries and we need
to use the
right the
uh
we need to make sure we're fully
sustainable in italy as well as everyone
er everywhere else today is the world
day of the press-free freedom let's show
that we stand true to our values let's
free julian as
assange make sure that europe represents
peace
thank you
begin and that brings to a close round
of speakers and i once again invite
prime minister draghi to take the floor
to conclude the debate
well let me begin by
thanking all the heads of
groups
for their words of appreciation
that they used
when talking about my country
that's very important to me
and i must admit
i've been surprised by what you've said
and been moved so thank you again
i'd like to thank the president of the
european parliament of course for this
opportunity
to hold this discussion which
for me
is the first time since i left the
european central bank that i've been
able to
speak in the european parliament it's
been three years that i haven't had that
opportunity
let me go into two or three specific
points
before
i
talk about
what i think
is
our
shared goal in terms of our vision for
europe so a couple of specific points
would i
be in favor would italy be in favor of
an embargo on all fossil fuels well as i
said in my introduction we've supported
all sanctions that the eu's decided to
levy on russia including those on the
energy sector and will continue to do
that
in the future with the same
determination
we need to act though we can't simply
support sanctions we need to ensure that
we can achieve independence from russian
gas this we're acting in this manner and
will continue to act
so we've moved
exceptionally rapidly to try and
diversify
our energy supplies and to speed up
investments in renewables
and this was we've done at a rhythm that
wasn't envisaged last year and measures
taken yesterday by the government also
lead
to a liberalization of authority the
authorization process to set up
renewables projects because this is the
only
obstacle there is at the moment in italy
and also probably in other
european countries
i think we've taken a significant step
forward on that
for italy
with the decisions we took yesterday
now
businesses
that have made profits and poor families
well
there's no doubt
that businesses who are active
in the import of fossil fuels and in the
electricity sector have made massive
profits
just think about norway
whose profits just recently were
estimated at 150
billion
dollars
for a country with a very small
population five million i think the same
thing is happening to an italian and
other businesses who import fossil fuels
yesterday the government decided to
renew
this
tax on businesses extraordinary profits
so taxes on businesses who've imported
products including energy of all kinds
taxes have now reached
25
on these extra profits
the total amount we're talking about is
around 11
billion
if you include the first measure we took
and this second measure we've taken
and we've thereby
managed
to
provide a flat rate payment to 28
million people
and
these payments have gone to workers and
pensioners who are on low incomes
here i'm talking about the people who
are in the lowest income brackets people
who earn up to 35 000 euros a year
and they will all receive this flat rate
payment so it's a very progressive
measure
which
helps
the lowest earners
and
in some cases
compensates them for their loss of per
purchasing power that they're suffering
as a result of inflation so this is a
way in which we've been able to
help our poorest families without
necessarily
undermining
the solidity of our public finances and
this is very important for us because
our finances
need particular care
now
moving on to the environment
when this government
took office
it was born as an environmental
government so the climate and the green
and digital transitions are the main
pillars of what we want to do
the minister for the environment
our minister environment minister has
done an extraordinary job
and has done something that it would
have been very difficult to imagine even
a year and a half ago the minister has
come up with extraordinary measures
we may well not agree on the super bonus
of 110
and we don't agree on the validity of
that measure let me give you an example
i don't want to go on a too great length
the cost
of
making a building more efficient
has gone up by over three times thanks
to this measure
the prices
or the price of investing
in
refurbishments
has
almost tripled because this 110
measure
means that there's no incentive for
people to bargain on prices so that's
the result but in any case things are
moving forward in parliament the
government has done what it can do and
our minister for the environment is
excellent
now
changes to the recovery and resilience
plan
well the first
problem
here
is to ensure
that
public
works
continues and that new tenders open up
and yesterday the government earmarked 3
billion essentially to enable businesses
to recover 90
of the increase in raw materials costs
this measure was welcomed
by industry of course
industry that is involved in business
building infrastructure and is involved
in public works but actually was
welcomed right across the board and this
is the path that we've chosen
so before we talk about
changing the recovery and resilience
plan let's make it work i mean it's not
old hat at all
we've respected all our objectives will
continue to do it by the end of june and
we'll do the same at the end of december
so it's certainly not
outdated i mean if it does become
necessary to change certain things in
some points for some sectors yes but
specific investments we don't want to
change the recovery and resilience plan
completely i mean there are certain
minor changes that might have to be made
and if there are then we will make those
changes
so those were the things
that i wanted to say in terms of
specific matters
but now
let me
move on
to the overall
vision that
we're talking about today and i think
the nature
of what we're talking about is that we
basically share
ideals projects and ideas the european
union
faces many challenges
i
would like to agree with the last
political group speaker who said that
the most important challenge we face is
peace
and that's clearly the main goal that we
need to move towards
the european
union
is
acting along those lines as is my
government but there are many other
things that we want to achieve as well
and
when it comes to all these challenges
the response is that more integration is
the best way to go is the best way to
deal with all these challenges i talked
about pragmatic federalism
and that means that for many of these
challenges the only way to go
is to tackle them together and that
doesn't only mean pooling our funding i
mean i'm a banker and people think that
the only thing i think about is money
but
that's not
the only thing we can do
dealing with challenges together means
designing the solutions together it
means monitoring what we're doing
together it means ensuring that all of
us ensure that the money is spent
properly and italy is fully aware of
that and as you all know because i've
said it many times italy
is aware that it has a great
responsibility when it comes to spending
these funds that have come under the
next generation fund appropriately
and we will also be responsible when it
comes
to decisions on energy and decisions on
public investment also the digital and
green transitions
these are challenges
which
are
major in scope you know that uh certain
calculations have been made on the
digital and green transitions and
according to those calculations
by 2030 the funding need for the entire
european union is around two trillion
euros and these aren't figures
that national budgets can come up with
on defense
well again there are two goals
firstly strategic independence
and we've said several times that a
strong europe means a strong nato but in
order to achieve strategic autonomy as i
said in my introduction the first step
is to ensure that our military
expenditure is more efficient
as i said earlier we spend three times
as much as russia and it would be
unthinkable to do anything effective
without making our defense expenditure
more effective and more coordinated and
that's why i've called for a conference
to look towards that goal
i share
the need of
achieving
independence when it comes to
producing certain things that are
essential for our continent microchips
for example
that's
one example but there are other things
that are crucial for our supply chains
and
we need strategic independence
for those things
the war but also
before the war recent events i think
have shown that
production chains and markets don't
always
work in a fluid manner
and problems and bottlenecks can lead to
serious crises so we need to tackle
those challenges as well
that's this pragmatic federalism but i
also talked about perfect
federalism
the federalism of ideals and our values
are currently facing challenges that are
unprecedented since the launching of the
european union and given those
challenges we need to stand together
that's
where
this federalism of ideals can be seen we
need to find solutions that are joint
solutions
in spite of the fact that we're all very
different because of our histories our
traditions because of our starting
points and that's
the real difficulty that we have to get
over
and we need to deal with that difficulty
in order to be successful as europe
and let me conclude
now
by saying
that
if all of this
requires
a procedure of treaty change
let's go for treaty change
bravely and in a confident manner
thank you very much prime minister
draghi and that closes this debate and
we move on to the next one thank you
very very much to all
you